- Which daughter is this though
singing with the dog?
(howling)
(dog howling)
(laughing)
(howling)
(dog howling)
Oh my god it's so cute.
Which daughter is that?
- That's Maggie.
That's the middle daughter
and Stromboli's the dog's name, yeah.
- Very Italian, I like it.
- Yeah well, he's, he's a,
he's just, he's he's a glorified bird dog.
He has, but he's Italian,
I think he's called an Italian Bronco
so we had a family of those
dogs and he's the last one left.
Well we have one more
at the form, but, but,
so we named them all Italian names.
- I love that y'all are both singers
and even your dog's sing.
That's awesome.
(laughing)
It really is in the family.
- To be fair Stromboli's
sings a lot better than me.
I'm probably the worst
singer in the house.
- Oh, shut up,
I'm seeing you laugh.
That's what I found so funny
that I've seen you live,
you and Faith and you came backstage
and you were like,
"Oh man, if I'd known you were here
I would have sang better."
I was like,
you did an awesome job of singing along.
I was like, them both killed it.
Like you're so humble, whatever.